This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
这是一档由I-Heart制作的播客。品质真人保证。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听《硬着头皮学》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖恩斯。这个节目聚焦黑人男性的经历，进行那些在其他地方绝对无法畅所欲言的坦诚对话。但在这里，你是在和一个懂行的执业专业人士交流。有多少男人披着一身铠甲？这向世界传递出的信号是：别想惹我。但这并不意味着只要你有这个能力，就必须这么做。听听如何了解
the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier,
用硬核的方式，在IHeart电台应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈尔斯·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧、体能训练以及在我们这个奇异的现代世界中培养韧性的科学。经历一些磨难，你会破茧成蝶，成为一个更快乐、
more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends.
更充实、更健康的人。请在IHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子交往过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我要成为他的最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。他会得到应得的下场。我们总是说，相信你的好闺蜜。
Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 is big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
在IHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《相信我，宝贝》。在《回味往昔》播客中。从1979年开始，那对我和我来说是一个重要的时刻。84年对我很重要。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每集我们挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着去理解我们是如何挺过来的。
With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax.
和我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及最喜欢的作家们一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为对黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。在IHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回味往昔》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控生下了一对双胞胎。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。
You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police.
你曾多次篡改过这个特定的测试，对吗？我只篡改过一次测试。互联网侦探们动用了大量人手，才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一名女同性恋，迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的天哪，我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。
As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody. I'm Gemma Speck and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast, new listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we, of course, break down the psychology of our 20s. Today, guys, I have some big news. I moved to London. Might not be big news for some of you who follow me on Instagram, but it's true. I have made, the leap across the pond, the psychology of your 20s is officially a UK-based podcast.
随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。在IHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《爱情陷阱》播客。大家好。我是杰玛·斯佩克，欢迎回到《20多岁的心理学》，在这里我们探讨20多岁时面临的最大变化、重要时刻和人生转型，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客，新听友们，老听友们，无论你们身在世界的哪个角落。非常高兴大家能回来收听另一期节目，当然，我们在这里剖析20多岁的心理学。今天，伙计们，我有个重大消息。我搬到伦敦了。对于那些在Instagram上关注我的人来说这可能不算什么大新闻，但这是真的。我确实迈出了跨越大西洋的一步，《20多岁的心理学》正式成为一档英国本土的播客了。
It's been very exciting. And I want to talk about my decision to move overseas in my 20s, what's been going on, what we've learned, some of the failing, some of the harder parts, the cultural adjustments. And yeah, just some advice that I would give for people who want to do the same and how I'm going to plan. to meet friends and all that kind of stuff. Like there's just a lot to talk about. To begin with, I moved with my boyfriend with my lovely, amazing boyfriend. And I'm going to tell you the story of how we decided on London and kind of when we decided
这真的很令人兴奋。我想谈谈我20多岁时决定移居海外的决定，最近发生了什么，我们学到了什么，一些挫折，一些比较艰难的部分，还有文化适应。还有，是的，给那些想做同样事情的人的一些建议，以及我将如何计划结交朋友诸如此类的事情。总之有很多话要说。首先，我和我的男朋友一起搬过来了，和我可爱、优秀的男朋友一起。我要跟你们讲讲我们是如何决定去伦敦的故事，以及大致是什么时候决定的
and how we decided to move. So taking it all the way back to when I first met him, when I first met Tom, I feel like you guys know the story, but it was very unexpected. I was in Bali, I was on Hinge, and I matched with this guy, then ended up ghosting in for a little bit. That guy, I've now been with him for like almost three years and he's incredible. At the time that I met him, though, I just quit my full-time job and I was like, I'm a single girl in her 20s. I want to move to London. And for those who are in the UK or in Australia, you'll know it's like a big trend.
以及我们是怎么决定搬家的。所以，回溯到我第一次见到他的时候，我第一次见到汤姆的时候，我觉得你们大概都知道这个故事，但非常出乎意料。我在巴厘岛，在用Hinge，然后我和这个家伙匹配上了，结果他后来对我爱搭不理了一会儿。那个家伙，我现在已经和他在一起快三年了，他太棒了。不过，在我遇到他的时候，我刚辞掉全职工作，当时我想的是：我是一个20多岁的单身女孩。我想搬到伦敦。对于那些在英国或澳大利亚的人来说，你们会知道这就像是一个大趋势。
there's like a whole joke that you turn 25 in Australia and you move to London. Like it's a very classic like migratory pattern. Like a lot of people do it. I genuinely think that at this point I have more friends in like Australian friends in London than I did in Sydney because of just like, you know, how, how classic it is. And I was like, you know what? London sounds great. I like knew a lot of people here and I was going to move at the end of the year and then I met this amazing person. and I feel like when I met Tom, I was in such a great, centered headspace of like, a man does not come first. And if this guy who I obviously am really into, like, isn't, doesn't have the same dreams
有个笑话就是你在澳大利亚满25岁了然后就会搬到伦敦。就像是一个非常经典的迁徙模式。很多人都这么做。我真心觉得，现在我在伦敦的澳大利亚朋友，比我在悉尼的朋友还要多，就因为你知道的，这太经典了。然后我想，你知道吗？伦敦听起来真不错。我在这里认识不少人，我本来打算年底搬过来的，结果我遇到了这个超棒的人。我觉得当我遇到汤姆时，我的心态非常棒、非常平和，觉得：男人并不是第一位的。如果这个我显然很心动的家伙，没有和我同样的梦想
as me, that's okay, but like I'm not going to pretend it's going to work. So very quickly I said to him, I want to let you know, like, I really plan on living overseas, wherever that may be, like my heart's really set on like either London, or like Seattle or I think I also really wanted to move to Copenhagen. And I was like, my heart's really set on that. So, you know, it is a deal breaker. If that's not in your life plans, can you let me know? He like took some time away and was like,
也没关系，但我不会假装我们能合适。所以很快我对他说我想让你知道，我真的很想去海外生活，无论那个地方在哪里，我的心真的锁定在伦敦、西雅图，或者我想我真的很想搬去哥本哈根。我就这样告诉他，我的心意已决。所以，你知道的，这是一个底线问题。如果这不在你的人生规划里，你能告诉我吗？他花了一些时间考虑，然后说：
I've decided that I would really want to do that with you if things go well. Obviously, we've literally been dating for six months. Now that I think about it, it's just a little bit wild that I was like, so when are we going to move overseas? And he's like, I don't even know your blood type. I don't know your parents, like, you know, but I would recommend it. We got very clear on it. He is a lawyer.
如果一切顺利的话，我决定我很想和你一起去。显然，我们当时实际上才约会了六个月。现在想来，我当时说“那我们什么时候出国搬家呀？”真的有点疯狂。而他则说：“我甚至都不知道你的血型。我还不认识你的父母，你知道的，”但我还是会推荐这么做。我们在这方面达成了非常明确的共识。他是一名律师。
I don't know if I've told, said that before, but he's a lawyer. And in Australia, you become a lawyer and then you have to do two years of like professional practicing. So technically he's a lawyer, but you've got to get this thing called P.A. You've got to practice. And then you can become like a, I'm going to butcher it, but like a licensed lawyer. Like you can practice without supervision. It's kind of the same with like doing. residency as a doctor. And he said to me, you know, I have to do this though. So here's the kicker.
我不知道我之前有没有说过，但他是一名律师。在澳大利亚，你成为一名律师后，必须进行两年的专业实习。所以严格来说他是一名律师，但你必须拿到一个叫P.A.的东西。你得实习。然后你才能成为像——我可能说得不太准确——那种持证律师。就像你可以不用在监督下独立执业一样。这有点像医生的住院医师培训。他对我说，你知道的，我必须经历这个过程。所以重点来了。
If you want to move, you're going to have to give me two years because he literally just become a lawyer. So you're going to have to give me two years. And I, yeah, you know what? Now that story has a good end. But at the time, like, everybody was like, why are you doing that? Like, why are you going to put your life on hold, put a dream that you have on hold for two years for this guy that you've only known for six months and, like, hope it's going to work out. And he says he wants to come with you. you, but what if he doesn't? I knew I could trust him. The two years just like flew by. At the start of this year, we sat down and we were like, are we going to do this? Like, is this something that we're going to do? You know, that was a goal I set. And you really, he also was really keen on like a little
如果你想搬家，你得给我两年的时间，因为他才刚刚成为律师。所以你得给我两年。然后，是的，你知道吗？现在那个故事有了一个好结局。但在当时，所有人都说：“你为什么要这么做？为什么为了一个你才认识六个月的家伙，就把你的人生暂停两年，把你的一场梦想暂停两年，然后还指望它能顺利进行？他说他想跟你一起去，但如果他不想呢？”我知道我可以信任他。这两年就像飞一样过去了。今年年初，我们坐下来讨论：我们真的要这么做吗？这真的是我们要落实的事情吗？你知道的，那是我设定的一个目标。而且你真的——他其实在不久前也表现得非常热切——
while ago now. Like time, like a year in your 20s is a is like five years. Like so much can change during that time. Like, is this still something that we want to do? And, you know, he said, I'm so freaking Absolutely. Let's do it. So we set a date. We like December works really, really well because obviously that's when he passes, like, finishes his PAE. And we booked our flights and it all happened very, very quickly. This is the ironic thing. This is the weird thing. To have a plan, like, we should have planned more, right? We knew this was going to happen for two years. And I genuinely think we only made the plans for it to happen in the last two months. Like I know that we, we, we book, our flights in October. Mainly because life is just very busy and chaotic and it's not that we
20多岁时的一年就像是五年。在这期间，会有太多的事情发生改变。这依然是我们想做的事吗？你知道的，他说：“我太想去了！绝对的，我们走吧。”所以我们定了一个日期。我们觉得十二月非常非常合适，因为显然那就是他通过、结束他的PAE的时候。我们订了机票，一切都发生得非常非常快。这就是具有讽刺意味的地方。这就是奇怪的地方。要说制定计划，我们本该计划得更周详一些，对吧？我们知道这件事两年了。而我真心觉得我们是在最后两个月才开始着手安排搬家计划的。我知道我们在十月份才订了机票。主要是因为生活实在是太忙碌、太混乱了，并不是说我们
weren't committed to going, but I think we were just like, when is going to be the right time? Do we do before Christmas, after Christmas? And it just kind of ended up working that, yeah, we've moved right before the holidays and it's beautiful and it's Christmasy. So far, it has been incredible. Here have been the biggest adjustments. Firstly, is the weather and the sunlight. And I know that's like so cliche and so many people talk about it. When I'm in Australia, I spend, I would say a good three to four hours outdoors a day. I'm walking my dog. I go for walks.
不打算去，而是我们一直在想：什么时候才是最合适的时机？我们是在圣诞节前去，还是圣诞节后去？最后结果就是，我们在假期前夕搬了过来，这很美好，而且很有圣诞的气氛。到目前为止，一切都棒极了。以下是我面临的最大适应问题。首先是天气和阳光。我知道这听起来太老套了，很多人都在谈论这个。当我在澳大利亚时，我每天大概有整整三到四个小时在户外。我遛狗，我去散步。
I work in my backyard. I really like the sunshine and it really doesn't get that cold. Some people complain about it, but it's like it's really not that bad. The sun setting at like 4 p.m. has smashed me and also made it very very much. very hard to fight jet lag because as soon as it hits 4 p.m. I want to have like a little mold wine and I want to go to bed and what baby wants baby gets. So I've been letting myself do that. I've been like holding out to like 7.38. But definitely like I'm the jet like is is making it harder and I just feel like the difficulty of being indoors a lot more and not getting
我在后院办公。我真的很喜欢阳光，而且那里真的没那么冷。有些人抱怨它冷，但其实真的没那么糟。下午4点太阳就落山了，这简直把我击垮了，同时也让我很难克服时差，因为一到下午4点，我就想喝点热红酒，然后就想上床睡觉了。宝宝想要什么，宝宝就能得到什么。所以我一直顺从自己。我一直在苦苦撑到晚上7点、8点。但毫无疑问，时差让这一切变得更加艰难，而且我觉得花更多时间待在室内、晒不到
as much sunshine has been difficult. Also coming at Christmas time, I like the week we got here, I went and had dinner with like two of my best friends, Steph and Joe, who moved like three months before we did. And Steph, we were like having dinner and she was like, have you been shoved yet? And I was like, no, what the heck? And she was like, I was like, no, I haven't been shoved. Nobody's going to shove me. Like, I'm pretty tall. I'm like, got broad shoulders. Like, no one of those days, you're going to get shoved. You're going to get pushed. And then you're going to come to me and say, this today was the day that I shoved. I'm officially, I can say I'm living in London
充足阳光所带来的困难，确实挺难熬的。再加上正好赶上圣诞节，我们到这里的头一个星期，我和两个最好的朋友斯蒂芬和乔一起吃了晚饭，她们比我们早三个月搬来。在吃晚饭时，斯蒂芬突然问我：“你被人推搡过吗？”我说：“没有啊，什么鬼？”她说：“我跟你说，我还没被人推过呢。没人敢推我。我个子挺高，肩膀还挺宽。总有一天，你会挨撞的。你会被人推一把。然后你会来找我，说‘今天就是我挨推的日子’。我终于可以正式说我住在伦敦了。”
and then it literally happened the next day. Getting on the tube, getting on the bus, I feel like there's so much bodily contact with strangers that I don't have in Australia and a lot less like Cheerio and hi and chatting maybe just because it's winter. That's been a little bit of an adjustment. Also, you know, just to take a turn,
然后就在第二天，这事儿真的发生了。坐地铁，坐公交，我觉得这里跟陌生人之间的肢体接触比在澳大利亚要多得多，而且少了很多“嗨”或者“你好”之类的闲聊，也许这只是因为现在是冬天吧。这确实需要适应一下。还有，你知道的，话锋一转，
like there was like a terrorist attack in Australia when like a less than. five days after we got here. It was like this anti-Semitic terrorist attack in a place that like we called home and that we visited and that we knew. To my best friends used to live across the road from where the festival, the Hanukkah festival was being held. And I remember like this is wild, but two years ago when it was being held, I was pet sitting there
就在我们到达后不到五天，澳大利亚发生了一起恐怖袭击。那是一起反犹太恐怖袭击，发生在一个我们称之为家、我们曾经去过、我们非常熟悉的地方。我的两个最好朋友过去常常住在举办光明节庆祝活动的那个街区对面。我记得——这真的很疯狂——两年前庆祝活动举行时，我在那里帮别人
dog and watching the festival and to think that like yeah oh my god i need to not get emotional about it because it's very sad but um you know in australia like this stuff doesn't happen and i know everybody says that but it really doesn't and it's so shocking and it's been hard i'm excited about living in london but it has been hard feeling like you want to mourn and grieve and be around friends and family, but they're thousands of miles away and you don't live in that city anymore. And everyone around you in this new city that you live in is carrying on as usual. And it just doesn't feel it. It's just a weird transplant moment where you're like, I just want to talk to somebody about
看狗，顺便看着那个节日。一想到——天哪，我得克制一下自己的情绪，别太激动，因为这真的很悲伤——但是，你知道的，在澳大利亚，这种事情是不会发生的。我知道每个人都这么说，但这确实不会发生，这太令人震惊了。这段时间真的很难熬。我对住在伦敦感到兴奋，但一想到你想哀悼、想悲伤、想和亲朋好友在一起，而他们却在数千英里之外，你不再住在那座城市了，这种感觉真的很艰难。而你现在居住的新城市里的每个人都在照常生活。这种感觉很不真实。这是一种奇怪的异乡移植时刻，你会觉得：我只想找个人聊聊
this. And yeah, everybody's just kind of going on about that day. Like when Australia is asleep, we're awake. And so, you know, you go to bed and then all this news comes in and you wake up and you have nobody to really process it with. And there's a lot of Australians in London and in the UK. And it's been this weird experience where I was in Sainsbury's the other day. And I like heard somebody with an Australian accent. And I just like, it was weird. I like wanted to, um, oh my God, I don't want to cry. But like, like, I wanted to go over and say hi and just be like, it was like this weird
这件事。然而，是的，每个人都在继续过着他们的日子。当澳大利亚在睡觉时，我们是醒着的，所以，你知道的，当你上床睡觉时，所有的这些新闻都涌进来了，而当你醒来时，你身边真的没有人能和你一起消化这些情绪。伦敦和英国有很多澳大利亚人。经历了一段非常奇怪的体验，前几天我在塞恩斯伯里超市时。我听到有人带着澳大利亚口音。这感觉好奇怪，我真想去——天哪，我不想哭——但我真想走过去跟他们打个招呼，就好像有一种奇怪的
gravitational pull of like this terrible thing has happened. And like, it was, I'm not going to go up to a stranger and be like, hey, can you help me process? Like, I don't know, like my weird disenfranchised grief and maybe also guilt for not being able to support the victims and my friends and family. So, yeah, wow, that took a turn. It took a turn. But it's just in a weird experience being, like, just wanting to do something for your community and these people and they have lost their, like, lives and these victims and having to just kind of watch from a thousand miles away and and hope that like the love that you're sending from afar is being received and that I don't know um
引力牵引着我，发生了这么可怕的事情。而且，我总不能跑去对一个陌生人说：“嘿，你能帮我消化一下情绪吗？”我不懂，就像我这种奇怪的、失去归属感的悲伤，可能还有因为无法支持受害者以及我的朋友和家人而产生的负罪感。所以，是的，哇，话题转得真生硬。话题确实转得有点生硬。但这只是一种奇怪的体验，你只想为你的社区和这些人做点什么，而他们失去了生命，这些受害者们——而你却只能在几千英里之外默默地看着，并希望你从远方寄出的爱能够被接收到，并且，我不知道，呃……
it's just so awful it's just so awful but some of the like how do you change how do we how do we theme change from here let's talk about maybe apartment hunting there we go out it's funny because like as this has been happening like also like we don't really have a place to to live. And it was really stressing me out like when we got here and then this has happened. It just feels like it doesn't really matter as much. Like it's been very bizarre where I'm like, oh, you know, the first few days we were here, we got like some bad news that like our sublet had fallen through and these like, it's an amazing couple had like offered to let us sublet their home for three months because they were going to the US and then her visa got denied.
这真的太可怕了，太可怕了。不过，关于如何改变——我们该从哪里转换话题呢？我们来聊聊找公寓吧。就这样，说来也搞笑，就在这一切发生的同时，我们其实也没有一个真正能住的地方。当我们刚到这里时，这让我感到压力山大，接着又发生了那些事。感觉好像这些都不那么重要了。这种感觉真的很诡异，我在想，噢，你知道的，我们刚到的头几天，我们得到了一个坏消息，我们的转租泡汤了。这是一对非常好的夫妇，他们原本答应让我们转租他们的家三个月，因为他们要去美国，结果她的签证被拒绝了。
So we literally found out like on the plane that like, oh, we don't have anywhere to live come January. So it's been like this very rapid series of events and things that are going on. Apartment hunting in London is not for the week. I will just say that. The amount of price gouging that is happening, like people who will like we will offer and then they'll say, well, somebody else has just offered more and we've accepted their offer. But if you want to offer 900 quid, like we could totally. go for that. And then we're like, oh, yeah, okay, we can offer that. And they go, oh, bad luck. Like somebody else has come back with the other offer. I'm like, what is going on in this
所以我们简直是在飞机上才得知：“哦，到了1月我们无处可住了。”所以这是一连串非常迅速的事件和正在发生的事情。在伦敦找公寓真的不适合意志薄弱的人。我只能这么说。这里存在着大量的价格欺诈，比如有些房东，当我们提出报价后，他们会说：“哦，刚刚有人出了更高的价格，我们已经接受他们的报价了。但如果你愿意出900英镑，我们完全可以考虑。”然后我们就说：“哦，好吧，我们可以出这个价。”结果他们却说：“哦，真不走运。其他人又出了更高的价。”我就在想：这个地方到底怎么了？
location? And then just like getting references in and how quickly things move, fingers crossed by the time you're listening to this episode, we will have an apartment because we put in an offer. It got accepted. We put in our references. That literally happened within 24 hours. Like we reached out and like, we want to see the place. And then. And we saw it and then we put an offer and it was accepted and then they did our references. We haven't heard anything since. So I'm like, fingers crossed, it's going to be okay. But that has just been like a whole like experience of just of stress.
然后就是准备推荐信以及事情进展的速度。祈祷吧，希望等你们听到这一集的时候，我们已经租到公寓了，因为我们已经出了价。我们的报价被接受了。我们提交了推荐信。这简直是在24小时内发生的。我们联系了房东说：我们想看房。然后我们看了房，接着出了价，对方接受了，然后他们核实了我们的推荐信。从那以后我们就再也没有听到任何消息了。所以我只能祈祷一切都会顺利吧。但这整个过程就像是一场充满压力的经历。
Like moving countries is deeply, deeply stressful. And I think I was a little bit naive in thinking like it's not going to be that bad because I work for myself and like I don't have to job hunt. I thought that because I don't have to look for a job. is going to be really easy. No, it's just a major adjustment. And it's definitely like given me a bit of a flare up in, yeah, some obsessive thinking, some anxious thinking. And I, like, before we left, I was like, why am I so stressed? Why am I so emotional? And Tom and my friends were like, because you're moving countries. And I was like, yeah, but we're not there yet. So it's like,
跨国搬家带来的压力真的是太深、太重了。我想我当时有点天真，以为事情不会那么糟糕，因为我是自由职业，我不需要去找工作。我以为因为我不需要找工作，这一切就会变得轻而易举。不，这绝对是一个重大的适应过程。这绝对让我的某些问题复发了，比如强迫性思维、焦虑性思维。在离开之前，我还在想：我为什么这么大压力？我为什么情绪这么激动？汤姆和我的朋友们对我说：“因为你要搬到别的国家去了。”而我说：“对啊，但我们还没走呢。”所以我觉得，
it shouldn't be this overwhelming. And yeah, I think I definitely underestimated. Yeah, how, how overwhelming it's going to be. How weird it is to say goodbye to everything. everybody but still feel like, you know, you saw them a week ago, which is like kind of normal. You sometimes don't see your friends for a week, but knowing like you're not going to see them the next few weeks. And having that bit of loneliness as well, I've only been here for, I don't know, how long has it been? Like, genuinely a week. And I've already felt this pressure to like, how come I don't have any new friends here? It's like, you've been here for a week. And like, oh, how come we, our apartment that we don't even have the keys to isn't fully furnished
事情本不该这么让人喘不过气来的。是的，我想我确实低估了这会有多么令人窒息。向所有人、所有事物道别，但感觉好像你一个星期前才刚见过他们，这种感觉既正常又诡异——有时候你确实会一个星期不见朋友，但心里清楚接下来的好几个星期你都见不到他们了。同时也会伴随着一些孤独感。我到这里才——我不知道，到底过了多久？——真的只有一个星期。而我已经感到了这种压力：“为什么我在这里没有新朋友？”就好像：你才来了一个星期啊。还有：“为什么我们连钥匙都还没拿到手的公寓还没完全装修好呢？”
yet? And how come we don't have our UK bank accounts open? And, you know, I don't know if this has been your experience if you've moved countries in your 20s, but it feels like you get here and you expect your life to be pre-built and you forget that like the city you were in before and maybe the one before that, you had to build that from nothing and you had to build that up. That's not just going to be transplanted to wherever you are. So I'm excited about that process. I'm also very nervous about it.
“为什么我们的英国银行账户还没开好呢？”而且，我不知道如果你在20多岁时搬过国家，你是不是也有这种体验：你来到一个新地方，期望这里的生活已经提前为你建好了，而你却忘记了在你之前待过的城市，甚至在那之前的城市，你一切都是从零开始建立起来的，你是一点点把它建设好的。生活是不会自动复制粘贴到你所在的任何新地方的。所以我对这个过程感到兴奋，但同时也为此感到非常紧张。
And I want to talk about my approach, my game plan. I'm a very efficient person and I like to have my steps in place for how I'm going to achieve something, how I'm going to achieve friendship. So I'm going to talk about that after this short break. Stay with us. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory.
我想聊聊我的方法和全盘计划。我是一个效率很高的人，我喜欢为如何实现某个目标、如何建立友谊制定好具体的步骤。所以在短暂的休息之后，我会谈谈这个。请继续收听。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈尔斯·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧、体能训练以及在我们这个奇异的现代世界中培养韧性的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，穿透主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的曾深信种子油生来就会引起炎症。
We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl.
我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到惊慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。经历一些磨难，你会破茧成蝶，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请在I-Heart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》，即数字T-W-O-百分号。任何男人都应该遵守两条黄金法则。法则一，绝对不要去惹乡下女孩。
You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield. And in this new season of The Girlfriends, Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck.
玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的下场。法则二，也绝对不要去惹她的朋友。我们总是说，相信你的好闺蜜。我是安娜·辛菲尔德。在《闺蜜》的新一季中，天哪，这就是同一个人。一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子交往过。我感觉自己像是被卡车撞了。
I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the Girlfriends. Trust me, babe.
我在想：这种事怎么会发生在我身上？警察似乎根本不在乎。所以她们决定自己采取行动。我说：哦，见鬼去吧。我发誓。我要成为他的最后一个目标。他会得到应得的下场。在I-Heart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《闺蜜》节目，相信我，宝贝。
On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast.
在VMA颁奖典礼上，黛安娜·罗斯狠狠拍了两次小金（Lil' Kim）的胸部，你还记得吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不关心黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么鬼关系？好吧，你可以在《回味往昔》播客中找到答案。
I'm Sam Jay. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear,
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每集我们挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着去理解我们是如何挺过来的。包括最近一集与马克·拉蒙特·希尔的对话，他大谈80年代的快克可卡因。需要说明的是，
was big to me not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack, so I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now, so that you're finishing that sentence.
对我来说它很重要，不仅仅是因为快克。我随时准备一整天都聊快克，不过为了让大家知道我的意思。我是说，马克，到了这个时候，这已经是我们第二集讨论快克了，所以我开始看出这里有一条贯穿的主线了。我们现在甚至还把艾滋病摆上台面了，所以你接着把话说完吧。
I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast,
我认为没有比这更重要的一年了，对于黑人来说。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。在I-Heart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回味往昔》。欢迎收听我的新播客，
Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark.
《硬着头皮学》，我是主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师凯尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了自己十多年在心理健康领域的经验，以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾进行的对话。我说的是：特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。
Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we do. done enough because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's
有时当我们去追求某样东西时，我们太过于沉迷于追逐的过程，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它。而我们还在继续追逐。我们不知道什么时候才算足够，因为人们总是盯着记分牌。生活变成了关于输赢的游戏。史蒂夫·布恩斯、达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在这个世界上活着做一个好人很重要？你做个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为这是两种截然不同的动机，兄弟。绝对的。而那是
two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free, our heart radio app, search learn the hard way and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth.
两个不同层面的信任。我希望你能真正发自内心地去做一个好人。加入我，凯尔·盖恩斯，在我的新播客《硬着头皮学》中，我们将就疗愈、成长、父职、压力和人生目标展开真实的对话。打开免费的I-Heart Radio应用，搜索“learn the hard way”并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己陷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法院听证会暴露出她说法中明显的矛盾之处。这开启了一场长达数年的法庭之战来证明真相。
You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Gregalespian and Michael Marantini.
你曾两次篡改过这个特定的测试，对吗？我只篡改过一次测试。互联网侦探们动用了大量人手才破了案。我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税都被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们揭露出了一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·莱斯皮安和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until Justice is. served in Arizona.
我的天哪，我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被正式指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州，正义得到伸张之前，这一切都不会结束。
Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Okay, so we're here. We're in London. Here are a couple questions that people had for me about the move. The first is what is happening to Talu, my dog. So in case you don't know, I adopted a dog this last year, this year. And she's a line of my life and she is wonderful.
在I-Heart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《爱情陷阱》播客。好了，我们现在到了。我们在伦敦。以下是大家关于这次搬家向我提出的一些问题。首先是我的狗塔露（Talu）怎么处理。如果你还不知道的话，我在过去这一年里领养了一只狗，今年。她是我的生命之光，她太棒了。
it is quite difficult to get pets into the UK, but also to get pets back into Australia. This kind of feeds into another question, which is how long do you plan to stay? And the thing is, is that we don't know. So our decision process was there is no point putting her through the process of moving if in six months, even a year, we're like, we actually don't like it here. And we want to move back. So what we're going to do is give ourselves six months to make a decision on how long do we want to stay. And if it's less than a year, we won't move her over.
把宠物带进英国相当困难，要把宠物带回澳大利亚同样很难。这自然引出了另一个问题，那就是：你们打算待多久？问题是，我们自己也不知道。所以我们的决策过程是这样的：如果仅仅过了六个月甚至一年，我们就发现其实并不喜欢这里，并想要搬回去，那么让塔露经受折腾搬过来就毫无意义。所以我们要做的就是给自己六个月的时间来决定我们到底想待多久。如果时间少于一年，我们就不把她接过来。
And if it's more, then we will. Trust me, she is fine. She is having the time of her life. She's staying with my parents and my sisters. They really wanted another dog. Really wanted another dog. But my childhood dog is quite elderly. and he's still alive and they didn't want to get a puppy or they didn't want to get, you know,
如果超过一年，我们就会接她来。相信我，她很好。她过得可开心了。她正和我父母以及我的姐姐妹妹们住在一起。他们一直很想再养一只狗。真的很想再养一只狗。但我们从小养到大的那只狗年纪已经很大了，
a new untrained dog when our childhood dog was still alive. And like, you know, you don't want his replacement to be sitting right there. It's kind of like a weird cruel thing. But they did really want like another dog in the house, especially as he's getting older. And it just kind of worked out perfectly. Also, because my parents are going to be empty nesters in the next couple of years. They didn't want to get a new dog and then be like, now we don't have any kids at home to like play with this dog and you know my sisters really want a dog
它现在还活着，他们不想养一只小狗，或者说他们不想在从小养大的狗还在世的时候，去弄来一只未经训练的、全新的狗。而且，你知道的，你肯定不希望那只狗的“替代品”就这么直接坐在那里。那种感觉有点像是一种奇怪而残酷的事情。但他们确实很想家里再有一只狗，尤其是在老狗年纪越来越大的情况下。这一切可以说是完美契合。另外，因为我父母在接下来的几年里就要成为空巢老人了。他们不想养一只新狗，然后却发现：“现在家里没有孩子来陪这只狗玩了，”而且你知道的，我的姐姐妹妹们虽然很想养狗，
but like you know they're going to be out of home and they're not going to take care of it and they're not going to be around so actually it's worked out really really well and her and my childhood dog get along very well it's very cute my sister also has this cat that she found uh who's very cute actually and they're like getting along and my other sister has a rabbit my three sisters i have a dog my sister has a rabbit, my other sister has a cat, they all look exactly the same. They are all a very specific kind of black and white animal. And like we always joke that that's like our, yeah, like that the reflection of our soul is in the pets that we chose, but the fact they all look the same is quite funny. Like we have the same pet in different fonts. So Tala was fine. Tala was very happy.
但她们以后总要离开家的，又不会去照顾它，也不常在身边。所以实际上，事情最后的安排真的非常非常棒。她和我小时候那只狗相处得很好，超级可爱。我妹妹还养了一只她捡来的猫，呃，其实非常可爱，它们相处得也很好。我另一个妹妹养了一只兔子。我的三个姐妹：我有一只狗，我妹妹有一只兔子，我另一个妹妹有一只猫，它们长得一模一样。它们全都是那种非常特定黑白相间的动物。我们总是开玩笑说，那是我们的，呃，就像是我们的灵魂在所选的宠物身上得到了反映，但它们长得全一个样真的挺搞笑的。我们拥有的是“同款宠物，不同字体”。所以塔露很好。塔露非常快乐。
Kind of hurt my feelings a little bit when like I don't actually think she knows that I'm gone. I'm sure she does, but my sister's are sending me photos. I'm like, this dog is having a great time. Not that I wanted her to feel sad, but I was like, oh, great. She already forgotten about me, which is both a good, happy and kind of like a bittersweet thing. Second question, how long are we going to stay? Sorry, to properly address that. Like, ultimately, my visa is for three years, and then we can apply for permanent residency.
当我觉得——其实她好像根本不知道我已经走了的时候——这甚至有点小伤心。我确信她是知道的，但我妹妹发给我的照片显示：这只狗过得可美了。并不是说我希望她感到难过，但我的第一反应是：哦，太棒了，她已经把我给忘啦。这既是一种美好、开心的事，又带有一点苦乐参半的感觉。第二个问题，我们要待多久？抱歉，为了准确回答这个问题。归根结底，我的签证是三年的，之后我们可以申请永久居留权。
If we love it, that's probably getting a little bit ahead of myself. I'm just going to see how the first six months goes. and if we love it, if we're enjoying it, if we're making progress towards loving it, we will stay, we will bring over our beautiful dog and hopefully be happy with that decision. But I also am like trying not to be afraid of saying I'm wrong and going back on decisions because they're not right. I had this big thing before I left of like, what if I moved to London and I don't like it? And, you know, people, and then I have to tell people I don't like it.
如果我们很喜欢这里，那可能有点想得太远了。我打算先看看前六个月过得怎么样，如果我们喜欢这里，如果我们乐在其中，如果我们朝着喜欢这里的生活稳步前进，那我们就会留下来，把我们可爱的狗狗接过来，并且希望对这个决定感到满意。但与此同时，我也在努力克服对“承认自己错了并推翻之前的决定”的恐惧，因为如果决定不对，就该及时调整。在离开之前，我心里有个巨大的纠结，那就是：如果我搬去伦敦却发现自己不喜欢这里怎么办？而且，你知道的，如果那样的话，我就得告诉别人我其实并不喜欢，
and I have to move home and I'm a failure. And like, I'm not having any of that anymore. I'm just cutting off that thought from my brain. If it's not right, I'm not going to linger. I'm not going to try and convince myself it's right. I'm going to give it the best I've got and then just trust that things are going to fall in the place. And if it's not and the feeling isn't there, we move on to the next thing. We move home.
然后我得搬回老家，那我就是一个失败者。我现在可不这么想了。我要把这种想法从我的大脑里彻底切断。如果这里不合适，我不会死缠烂打。我不会试图说服自己这里是对的。我会付出我最大的努力，然后坚信一切都会各得其所。如果不是这样，那种感觉不对，我们就进入下一阶段。我们搬回老家。
We move somewhere else. How am I going to make friends? This is not the first time I've moved to a new city that I do not. know. I moved to Canberra for university. I moved to Sydney after university. Now I live in London. I know that it's going to take three months to feel good about the decision, six months to feel like I have some friends and I have some community. And part of that is just time. I often give this advice to people who are like, I've moved to a new city, what do I do? You've got to about by the six month rule.
我们可以搬去别的任何地方。我要怎么交朋友？这已经不是我第一次搬到一个全然陌生的新城市了。我为了上大学搬去了堪培拉。大学毕业后我搬去了悉尼。现在我住在伦敦。我知道需要三个月的时间才会对这个决定感到舒心，需要六个月的时间才会觉得有了一些朋友和属于自己的社群。而这其中有一部分纯粹需要时间。我经常给那些对我说“我搬到了一个新城市，我该怎么办”的人这样的建议：你得遵守六个月规则。
The first three months are going to be really hard. The first six months are going to be difficult. But it's almost a science that like when you hit the six month mark, something will change for you, especially if this is where you're meant to be, especially if you're putting in the time and putting in the effort to making relationships, to making community. Six months is it.
前三个月会非常难熬。前六个月会十分艰难。但这几乎像是一门科学：当你达到六个月这个节点时，情况就会为你发生改变，特别是如果这里本就是你命中注定该来的地方，特别是如果你在建立人际关系、融入社群上投入了时间和精力的话。六个月就是关键。
And so I genuinely feel like I'm strapping myself in for this like marathon. on. I'm strapping myself in for the next six months and I'm just like, let's go. Let's work really hard at making this feel like home. The biggest things I'm going to be doing is I'm joining a book club, I'm volunteering, I'm joining a boxing group and I'm joining a run club. Ready made groups, communities like that that I can fit into and hopefully offer some services to or offer like and really just like be a part of have always been my goal. to when I moved to Sydney, I joined a life drawing class. I joined a climbing gym. I then like later on, I joined a pottery studio. Kind of fallen out of love with those hobbies, but I'm like, great.
所以我真的觉得自己已经系好安全带，准备迎接这场马拉松了。我系好安全带准备迎接接下来的六个月，我心里想的就是：冲吧。我们要全力以赴，让这里感觉像家一样。我要做的最主要的事情就是：加入一个读书俱乐部，去做志愿者，加入一个拳击小组，还有一个跑步俱乐部。像这样现成的团体和社群，是我能够融入其中、并且希望能为之贡献一些服务或者真正成为其中一部分的目标。当我搬到悉尼时，我加入了一个人体写生班。我加入了一个攀岩馆。后来，我又加入了一个陶艺工作室。虽然有点逐渐淡出那些爱好，但我觉得：太好了，
It's time for the next round and I made some wonderful, amazing friends that way. The other thing I'm committing to doing is same grocery stores, same coffee shops, same gym, same route to work. I, same restaurants like I want to meet the people in my neighborhood. that is genuinely how I made three of my like best friends when I moved to Sydney. I met them through consistently interacting with my environment and with like literally like the institutions of my community in a really consistent way because I was like if I have this routine and somebody else has this routine and it's similar, A, we're going to see each other a lot. B, we're probably going to be quite similar people. So that is something I always give
又到了开启下一轮的时候了。通过这种方式，我结交了一些非常棒、非常了不起的朋友。我承诺要做的另一件事是：固定的杂货铺，固定的咖啡店，固定的健身房，固定的上班路线。去固定的餐馆，就像我想认识我社区里的人一样。这真的就是我当初在悉尼时结交到三位最要好的朋友的方法。我是通过持续地与我的环境进行互动，并且以一种非常持续的方式去融入我社区的各种场所来结交到他们的。因为我想：如果我有这个日常规律，而另一个人也有这个日常规律，并且两者的规律相似，那么首先，我们会经常见到彼此；其次，我们俩很可能是相当类似的人。所以我总是建议人们这么做：
people advice to do is like, yes, explore your new city, but like say hi to people in your local spaces and show up to things at the same time across your week, you will meet like-minded people. The other thing I've asked my friends back in Australia and my friends already living here to do is to platonically set me up with people. I'm committed to the mutual friend route. if my friend likes somebody I would say 99% of the time I'm going to like them as well
是的，去探索你的新城市，但要在你当地的生活空间里和人们打招呼，并在每个星期的相同时间出现在各个活动中，你就会遇到志同道合的人。我让澳大利亚的朋友以及已经在这里生活的另一拨朋友帮我做的另一件事，就是为我进行柏拉图式的相亲（友情牵线）。我完全信奉通过共同朋友结识新朋友的路线。如果我的朋友喜欢某个人，我可以说99%的情况下我也会喜欢那个人的。
one of my like soul sisters Gracie this is how we met I'm using like things that I previously have evidence for I was in Sydney I was really lonely and I remember calling my dad up
就像我的灵魂伴侣格雷西一样，我们就是这样认识的。我用的是我以前经历过的证据，当时我在悉尼，真的很孤独，我记得我给爸爸打电话
and being like I just really want a friend and he was like ask your friends if they know anybody asked to be set up and we went on like a blind friendship date together and it was like love at first sight So I've already got a few of those things planned. And I'm also going to do some community events with the psychology of your 20s because
然后说我真的很想找个朋友，他说去问问你的朋友认不认识什么人，问问能不能给你介绍一下。于是我们一起去了一场盲目友谊约会，感觉就像是一见钟情。所以我已经计划好了其中的一些事情。我也打算利用《你的二十多岁心理学》举办一些社区活动，因为
I don't know if you guys know this. London is the biggest city of listeners. I've already met some of you here. I think I've already met like five or six of you. Shout out to the girls at UCLA who I ran into when I'd had a few wines the other night coming home in Camden. Thank you for saying hi. And I just feel like you guys are so cool.
我不知道你们知不知道这一点，伦敦是听众最多的城市。我已经在这里遇到你们中的一些人了。我想我大概已经遇到五六个了。向在卡姆登回家路上遭遇我几杯酒下肚时偶遇的加州大学洛杉矶分校的女孩们大声问好。谢谢你们跟我打招呼。我觉得你们真的太酷了。
and I'm totally down for like being friends with listeners, particularly because I feel like you guys and me would have so much in common and I think you guys are really cool. And every time I meet you, I want to be your friends anyways. So I'm going to lean in heavily to that. And I'm also going to join a co-working space. I think something that has made the last few months in Sydney particularly hard for me was because I knew I was leaving, I just like spent a lot of time at home. And I wasn't like,
而且我完全愿意和听众做朋友，尤其是因为我觉得你们和我有很多共同点，而且我觉得你们真的很酷。每次我见到你们，我都想和你们做朋友。所以我打算全力以赴地去实现这一点。我也打算加入一个联合办公空间。我觉得让我在悉尼的最后几个月变得格外艰难的原因是，因为我知道我要离开，所以我只是花了很多时间呆在家里。我并没有像
I wasn't going to my co-working space. I wasn't finding a new co-working space. I wasn't really putting anything new in place to make community and to get out of my house because I was like, there's not really a point. I'm going to be gone soon. And the thing is, is that it's like a terrible attitude to have. And it meant that I just spent a lot of time in my little second bedroom office dungeon and then was wondering why I felt so terrible. I'm not doing that again this time. I have booked my membership. I have booked my co-working space. I'm going to be the most jolly person at that we work and I'm going to make everybody be friends with me and I'm going to get out of my house and I'm going to be productive outside of my home. Another question somebody asked is
我没有去我的联合办公空间。我没有找新的联合办公空间。我没有真正采取任何新措施来融入社区并走出家门，因为我觉得反正也没什么意义，我很快就要走了。问题是，这是一种糟糕的态度。这意味着我把大量时间花在我那间小小的第二卧室办公室地下室里，然后还在纳闷为什么自己感觉这么糟糕。这次我再也不会这样做了。我已经预订了会员资格。我已经预订了联合办公空间。我将成为WeWork里最快乐的人，我要让所有人都和我做朋友，我要走出家门，在户外提高生产力。另一个人问的问题是
any advice I want to make a similar move from Australia to the UK. Um, okay, biggest piece of advice is the visa is going to cost you a lot more than you think, specifically because you have to pay the healthcare levy. So just take that into account and make sure that you are prepared for that. Don't buy the service. This is so oddly specific. Do not buy the service that says they will scan your documents for you because it is a lie. Sorry, I'm so angry about this.
有什么建议吗？我想从澳大利亚搬到英国，进行一次类似的搬迁。嗯，好吧，最重要的建议是，签证的费用会比你想象的要高得多，主要是因为你必须支付医疗附加费。所以把这一点考虑进去，确保自己对此有所准备。不要买那个服务。这具体得简直莫名其妙。千万不要买那个声称会帮你扫描文件的服务，因为那是骗人的。抱歉，我对这件事真的很生气。
But when I got my visa, they had like this optional service. It was like $50 and they'd scan your documents. And I did it. And guess what? They don't scan them. You have to scan them yourself. You have to send them to them to them and then they'll send them through for you. So don't listen to their lives.
但是当我拿到签证时，他们提供了一种类似的可选服务。大概50美元，他们会帮你扫描文件。我照做了。结果呢？他们根本不扫描。你必须自己扫描。你必须把文件发给他们，然后他们再帮你转发。所以不要听信他们的谎言。
They don't actually scan them. Sorry. Don't do that. Have at least, I would say, two months to three months of savings, maybe even more. It's kind of similar to when you quit your job, right? Because I'm assuming most of you will have to quit your job to move here. But even if you don't, like, it's an expensive. place to live. I've already noticed that. Something I took for granted is that we have GST included in
他们根本不会扫描。抱歉。不要那样做。我建议至少准备两到三个月的存款，甚至可能更多。这有点类似于你辞职的时候，对吧？因为我猜你们大部分人为了搬到这里都得辞职。但即使你不需要，这也是一个生活成本很高的城市。我早就注意到了。我曾习以为常的一点是，在
Australia. They do not. So you'll pay for your food and then it'll be like, wait, what the heck? 20% more on top of the bill because we don't have that, right? Like even if we do, it's quite minimal. It's an expensive city. Rent is really expensive. Save as much as you can also so that when you get here, you can kind of enjoy yourself and you don't feel like you're scrambling. You don't feel like you're very stressed that's something that we've had in the first few days not with jobs but with um housing and other things that are going on that just meant that it's a beautiful time in london it's christmas markets and it's been kind of hard to enjoy it because it's been like we have to go home and do all these things so if you can make money less of a stressor i would say do it also don't bring all of your bags on
澳大利亚，价格中包含了商品及服务税（GST）。这里没有。所以当你付完食物的钱后，会发现：等等，怎么回事？账单还要额外多出百分之二十，因为我们没有这种税，对吧？即使有，也是微乎其微的。这是一个消费很高的城市。房租非常贵。尽量多存点钱，这样当你来到这里时，就能好好享受生活，而不会觉得手忙脚乱。不会感到压力重重，我们在前几天就遇到了这种情况，不是因为工作，而是因为住房和其他正在发生的事情，这意味着伦敦正处于美好的时光，有圣诞集市，但却很难去享受它，因为我们总是得回家处理这些杂事。所以如果能让金钱不那么让人焦虑，我建议你一定要这样做。还有，不要把所有的行李都带上
the plane we took we've done two like big suitcases and one little mini carry on suitcase and like a backpack each. We had friends like ship their stuff over on a boat. It cost a lot of money to get an extra suitcase, especially since mine was overweight. It was like 40 kilos. But when they shipped it on the boat and then they went and picked it up, I think it was like so much cheaper. So that's an option. Don't bother bringing furniture. Bring as little as possible. Clear out your wardrobe. I brought too many clothes. I've gotten here. I'm not wearing them. Now I have to get rid of them when I'm already here and I paid to bring them over. Just really take like this. minimal approach. Like one of my neighbors said to me before we left, like, oh, this is like one of
飞机。我们当时带了两个大行李箱、一个小号随身登机箱和各自的一个双肩包。有些朋友是通过货船把东西运过来的。超重一个行李箱要花很多钱，尤其是我的行李箱超重了。大概有40公斤。但当他们通过货船托运并在到达后去取时，我觉得便宜太多了。所以这也是一个选择。不要费心带家具。能少带就尽量少带。清理你的衣柜。我带了太多衣服。来到这里后，我根本没穿。现在我人已经在当地了，却不得不把它们处理掉，而当初我还付钱把它们运了过来。真的采取这种极简主义的方法吧。就像我们离开前一位邻居对我说的那样，哦，这就像是
the rare opportunities you have to travel quite light through life. Like your soul is kind of not as burdened by physical possessions. You can go anywhere, be anything, choose anything. And that felt really nice to me. So I'm really trying to embrace that and live quite minimally in this moment. And I would recommend doing that as well also just because it saves you money and frustration. But those would be my biggest tips. I think in maybe three months, I think at the six month mark, actually I'm going to do another episode.
人生中少有的几次可以轻装简行去旅行的机会之一。你的灵魂不会被物质财产过多地压垮。你可以去任何地方，成为任何人，选择任何东西。这让我感觉真的很棒。所以我真的很想拥抱这种状态，在此时此刻过得非常极简。我也建议你们这么做，不仅因为这能帮你省钱和减少烦恼。但这些会是我最重要的建议。我想大约三个月后，其实应该是在满六个月的时候，我会再录一期节目。
If you guys want it, of course. I'm going to do another episode about my thoughts. Right now, yes, a lot of has happened in the first week that we've been here. I'm still incredibly optimistic about it. And maybe I'm like applying my like Sydney learnings to London when it is a different city and might be a bit harder to get my foot in the door in terms of routines and community and friendship,
当然，如果你们想听的话。我会再录一期节目谈谈我的想法。目前来看，是的，我们到这里的第一个星期发生了太多事情。对此我依然抱有极大的乐观。也许我是在把在悉尼学到的经验套用到伦敦，而伦敦是一座不同的城市，要在日常作息、社区和友谊方面打开局面可能会更难一些，
but I am really committed to trying and for not making the same mistakes that I've made previously when I've moved to new cities, which is only relying on the friends I already have there and being kind of isolated. So I'm going to give you guys an update in six months. Maybe like the next thing you'll hear about this, like I'm back in Australia and we just won't address it ever again.
但我真的下定决心要去尝试，不再犯我以前搬到新城市时犯过的那些错误，也就是只依赖我已经在那里认识的朋友，从而变得有点孤立。所以我会在六个月后向大家作个更新。也许你听到关于这事的下一条消息就是，我回澳大利亚了，而我们再也不会提起这件事。
But I have a good feeling about it, just like I have a good feeling about 2026. So yeah, let's see what happens. I'm really excited. I want to also thank you guys for like, you know, obviously listening to the podcast and allowing me to move here and yeah, you made this happen for me. So I feel like it's my win. It's also a win for all of us. And I really appreciate all the listens from this year and all the support. I'm in a really like grateful sappy mood. I'm just very emotional at the moment. So yeah, I'm just projecting. I just being like, I love you guys all so much. But it's true and I'm very grateful, especially with my book this year and with the tour.
但我有一种很好的预感，就像我对2026年有很好的预感一样。所以，是的，让我们拭目以待吧。我真的很兴奋。我也想感谢大家，当然是收听播客并允许我搬到这里，是的，是你们帮我实现了这一点。所以我觉得这是我的胜利。这也是我们所有人的胜利。我非常感谢今年所有的收听和支持。我现在处于一种非常感恩、多愁善感的氛围中。我目前情绪非常激动。所以，是的，我只是在投射情感。我只想说，我非常爱你们大家。但这是真的，我非常感激，尤其是今年我的书和巡回演出。
And I'm excited to do a lot more stuff in Europe. So if you're a European listener, if you're a London listener, hopefully I'll get to meet you this year, next year. Hopefully I'll see you around. That sounds strange to say. But hopefully we're going to be friends. That's something I'm really looking forward to. If you enjoyed this episode, maybe leave a little British emoji in the comments down below, especially if you've made it this far. If you are, have moved cities, move countries in your 20s, or if you are a London listener, give me some tips, what should I know? What's something that you wish you knew when you moved here or moved anywhere?
我很兴奋能在欧洲做更多的事情。所以如果你是欧洲的听众，如果你是伦敦的听众，希望今年、明年我能有机会见到你。希望能在附近见到你。说这话听起来有点奇怪。但希望我们能成为朋友。这是我非常期待的一件事。如果你喜欢这一集，也许可以在下方的评论区留下一个英国小红旗表情符号，特别是如果你坚持听到了这里的话。如果你搬过城市，在二十多岁时搬过国家，或者你是伦敦的听众，请给我一些建议，我应该知道些什么？有什么是你希望自己在搬到这里或任何地方之前就知道的吗？
Also follow us on Instagram at That Psychology Podcast or at Gemma Spagg if you want to see some more personal updates with my transition to London life. And until next time, stay safe, be kind, be gentle to yourself. We will talk very, very soon. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences,
也请在Instagram上关注我们：@That Psychology Podcast或@Gemma Spagg，如果你想看到更多关于我过渡到伦敦生活的个人动态。直到下次，保持安全，保持善良，对自己温柔一点。我们很快就会再次交谈。嘿，最近怎么样？欢迎收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯（Kear Games）带来的《艰难学习》（Learn the Hardway）。这个空间专门探讨黑人男性的经历，
having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
进行在任何地方都绝对不安全的坦诚对话，但你是和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士在交流。有多少男人身披一副铠甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你就必须这么做，请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《艰难学习》。
2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，心理韧性、健身和建立恢复力的科学原理。
Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO%. On the IHeart Radio app. Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist,
经历一些艰难困苦，你最终将成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的走出困境的人。收听《2%》。即TWO%。就在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，
they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友们。收听《女友们》（The Girlfriends）。相信我，宝贝。就在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方。
On the Look Back at it podcast For 1979, that was a big moment for me 84 was big to me I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it
在《回顾过去》（Look Back at it）播客中，对于1979年，对我来说那是一个重大的时刻，84年对我也意义重大。我是萨姆·J（Sam J.）。我是亚历克斯·英格利什（Alex English）。在每一期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试着理解我们是如何在
with our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to Look Back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you can
我们的朋友、喜剧同仁和最喜欢的作家的陪伴下幸存下来的。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）谈论80年代。84年是一个疯狂的年份。那是一个疯狂的年份。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你可以收听的任何地方收听《回顾过去》
Get your podcasts. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in selling, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
获取你的播客。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。你曾两次篡改了这个特定的测试结果，对吧？我篡改过一次测试。这动用了大批互联网侦探，才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一个同性恋。
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is love trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As this season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to LoveTraft podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Mancini）。我的脑子炸裂了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《深陷爱河》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着本季的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《深陷爱河》播客。这是一个IHeart播客。真人保证。本期节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。